citizens of the reject Nation we are
back once again for the last of the
episodes of season one of the last of us
we have survived to the end
Sarah Erickson joining me once again how
are you Tara I made it all the way here
with butter lettuce on my head so I feel
like I'm doing pretty great you are
doing pretty great I must say this is
Peak bit dedication right now all right
Primetime comedy we're gonna watch the
season one finale of The Last of Us
thank you so much for joining us and for
making these so much fun thanks to Greg
for putting us together for coming up
with this take on the series and to you
guys for keeping us fresh and unspoiled
along the way uh as always if you could
leave a like on the video and subscribe
to the real rejects as well as to Tara
Erickson and upon your subscription if
you could also ring that Bell
the heavy metal remix yeah and also be
sure to check out Tara Erickson's
culinary online experience La Pizza
drinks yeah we're on Instagram if you
want to see where we eat and drink
around Los Angeles and get better
lettuce I mean I'll show you where I got
this I'm here for all of it and you
should be too absolutely and if you want
to be here for like all of all of the
reaction as well come on over to
patreon.com the real reject sync up with
your own copy and enjoy the full Last of
Us experience alongside Tara and I
alongside Greg and Andrew go on over and
check out Greg and Andrew's reaction
highlights as well they are a blast as
well if you want the full-on gamer
perspective and uh without further Ado
Tara
it's
so cool
[Music]
sorry to ruined up the video guys but I
just got to tell you the real rejects
are gonna be having a panel at WonderCon
Sunday 11 o'clock a.m to 12 p.m get your
tickets get your tickets
oh no
oh the baby's coming
laughs
this is no place to have a child oh my
nah man this kid's got a bright future
ahead look at the color of her dress
symbolism Tara yeah she's the color of
the virus
oh
God go find a bathtub or something quiet
place this
foreign
give yourself a switchblade section
no don't drop the weapon
[Music]
no
oh come on come on you could do it oh
God yes
I'll never get used to the little mouth
tendrils or the warts
oh what
that's one way to push oh boy pushed
right out oh wow okay best anesthesia
just get attached
no
oh this is probably her mom and that's
why she's oh
wow is that Ellie's mom I think so
[Music]
oh
no one
just gonna say before you saw her face
in the woods I was like is that Ellie it
looks kind of like Ellie yeah it's well
cast
yeah like she's gotta find a way to get
rid of the baby before
turns oh oh yeah get to playing it John
my guitar is is not in tune with this
it's okay my butter I tried just
I look so terrible now
it's like practice and practice so I was
like I'll only be able to play a bar or
two for copyrights
I'll play it separately you can come to
social media corporately
my butter lettuce is falling all over
the place y'all it's okay it's okay
don't worry we'll see how much longer it
can last with this on my head I'm
committed though for as long as I can be
committed which is
kind of up in the air
[Music]
beefed it yeah I did my best he did it
oh hey Marlene
hmm
wow oh what a moment yeah I want a
moment to come in we would delay getting
out of their Zone
hungry
take her with
with Boston
make sure that she's safe I can't do
that and I want you to give her this
oh
her name is Ellie
don't tell me your name now I have to go
how long have we known each other
yeah you gotta do it for your friend
now
and then you kill me oh
this actress looks so familiar too
oh she's great
oh
I can't kill you shoot her in the head
make it quick
Oh no you're supposed to as a friend
come on make it quick you had a buddy
with you let them do it yeah have him
shoot her
yeah
brand new ears
nice and quick
you didn't you didn't cover her ears
buddy dude
heck you've had one shots too you had
one thing to do
[Music]
wow hey kiddo quite an intro
Ellie do you hear me
no what
well I found this in there
Beefaroni Chef Boyardee Chef yeah choice
boggle boggle have you ever played this
Boggle
it's a weird game
interesting that we just find out now
she has like hearing loss from
do this for me
how far we've come hold my rifle
we had a guitar in that RV
it's all smashed up but got me thinking
maybe I should find one I haven't played
in Forever Joel I got you let's do this
boy I bet you'd be great at it
you want to learn how to play guitar yes
yes do I really
oh yeah
stop and ask her what's up Joel use your
fatherly instincts man you know
something's up just preoccupied okay so
this is what I'm thinking cut through
that building to get around that stuff
find a skyscraper gloves
uh actually this time I was thinking
we'd blast our way through that Rubble I
found some dynamite in that RV back
there huh
no so we're gonna cut through that
building find a skyscraper go up and
look around
never had you going didn't I
oh come on Joel what's wrong Ellie the
apocalypse got you down today
where's your joke book kid dude now is
the perfect time to puns yeah I'll get
you up there you can drop that ladder
down come on I'll give you a boost
huh
Do You Hear What uh yeah
she's great at playing this this note
one two five
oh
Jesus Christ Ellie got her groove back
but not the best way yeah
come on what the hell it's really a
video game
this way
come on
whoa
whoa oh my gosh
gosh so much I guess someone must have
broken open the zoo
it's all right
feed the little buddy come on yeah
yeah his friend ride the giraffe
laughs
oh it's so good to see him smile for
reals
oh
is it everything you hoped for
God exception dance
can't deny that
a few good views over this journey
look I don't know exactly where this
hospital is yeah we'll find it
maybe there's nothing bad out there but
so far there's always been something bad
out there I'm only saying there's risk
of course we just go back to Tommy's we
forget about the whole damn thing
oh we've been through everything I've
done
you can't be for nothing
yeah yeah you got people to save I know
you want to protect me you have and when
we're done we'll go wherever you want
Tommy's
sheep Ranch
the moon All the Above
oh we'll follow you into the dark
we finished what we started the half of
us
oh
a couple little giraffes out there it's
so peaceful but I feel like shit's gonna
hit the fan no this is just gonna be
like a slice of Life episode and the
season I mean if there's giraffes out
there does that mean the Tigers and the
lines are on the other side and will
eventually
be feasting upon giraffes
it's not a bad guess let me have this
moment please bring the circle of life
into this
emergency medical camps
they had me in one just like this with
Sarah
no she was gone already
it's for this
huh the guy who shot and missed I
figured that would have happened later
second day
well I gotta hand it to the army people
they were way better at stitching you up
than I was it was me
oh
I was the guy who shot and missed okay
story time
Sarah died
and I couldn't see the point anymore
and I wasn't scared either I was ready
it's near time
I went to pull the trigger I flinched
I still don't know why interesting
so Time Heals all
sets them it wasn't time they did it
it was you
will you be my daughter I'm glad that
me too
[Music]
open up guys to emotionally reserved
people but it's such a great little
tender moment for
what
giraffe shitty puns yeah now you're
talking
people are making apocalypse jokes like
there's no tomorrow
too soon no it's topical
[Laughter]
[Music]
those are three out of ten seven minutes
no no no no no no no no no
all right oh no no oh gas not
disoriented explosion Vision no
oh
I hate these people smashed a white too
he's about to become hostile or
something
oh fire Focus fireflies
hey
where's Zoe she wasn't here
not even a scratch she's mostly worried
about you took out three of my guys
I lost half our crew crossing the
country
I have five men his only job was to
protect me I still almost got killed
what is over
she felt like hell to get here she would
have been dead on day one
we all know he understood me to her
she's being prepped for surgery
our doctor
he thinks that the cordyceps and Ellie
has grown with her since birth why is
she in surgery it makes normal cordyceps
think that she's cordyceps it's why
she's immune oh
multiply the cells in a lab produce
those chemical Messengers
and then we can give it to everyone a
cure
that is that was the mission
Court of Subs grows inside the brain
it does
what so like
she might die or get scrambled at the
very least there won't be any pain no
you take me to her you take me to her
right now
oh Joel
you don't understand
I promised her mother that I would
sing I'm the only one who understands
yeah I have no other choice
I do oh
better let him go see her it's not gonna
be pretty walking out to the highway
leaving there with this pack
oh no
he tries anything
shoot him dang she's cold she's got a
world to save I guess
just let him see her oh you got to push
them
you're gonna you're gonna push them over
the edge man
I didn't hear anyone say stop
downstairs
oh yeah I mean he's gonna corner you on
these stairs good luck buddies let's go
Atomic Joel Joel Wick
keep walking oh
he's nice he didn't even kill you
oh
[Music]
oh yes no return
here we go baby
[Music]
I have Goosebumps yeah
just make yourself some coffee
oh gosh that was close
oh yeah he's ice cold now
you don't mess with Ellie not with Joel
not now ice rolled
hmm
[Music]
God these floor shots too
walk in the path wow
[Music]
wow
like a video game
[Music]
what's your plan on hooker
how did you get in here I said unhook
her
I won't let you take her
whoa no more surgery now
ow cover her arm
first
Jesus
if you want to stay alive during an
apocalypse you gotta find Joel as a
friend
[Music]
I feel like he's grappling with like did
he do the right thing if it was Gonna
Save yeah but if I'd be
but yeah it's like how much damage is
that gonna do to her brain
what is the greater good ugh can't keep
her safe forever
Marlene the doctor's dead what are you
gonna do you don't know how to cut him
out she lives in a broken world that you
could have saved Maybe
but it isn't for you to decide for you
so what would she decide
I don't want to do what's right
it's not too late even now
even after what you've done
oh
man
what it's all right you're with me
yeah we're running some tests on you
and some others
he probably shot her with that one turns
out there's a whole lot more like you
oh people that are immune oh oh goodness
the doctors they couldn't make any of it
work
they've actually oh
yeah they've stopped looking for a cure
Raiders attacked the hospital and barely
got you out of there
are people hurt
inevitably
keep lying Joel
at this point as well I'm taking us home
wow
oh
you just come after her
wow
Jesus Joel Joel he has taken a bit of a
turn sure
understandably so but still there's a
little bit very shocking
[Music]
wow
that's a beautiful shot
yeah good old way homie
the five hour hike
we can manage that
remember
yeah huh
well Sarah and I used to hike like this
all the time
that girl
she'd see a big rock and just
she would have liked you
not to say the two of you are the same
it's on your mind Ellie
well she was a lot more
I want to say girly and I'm not saying
that you're not girly I'm not
but you know why I think she'd like you
because you're funny
I think you would have made her laugh
only
anyway I bet you would have liked her
back
yeah but I would have
still feel like Ellie has some internal
some going on and we don't know yet oh
definitely
well I mean to her purpose is all sort
of yeah
when I got bit in the mall it wasn't on
my own
my best friend was there and she got bit
too if we didn't know what to do and she
says be a poetic and just lose our minds
together and then she did
and I had to
yeah
and then it was Tess and then Sam that's
not on you I know look sometimes things
don't work out the way we hope
you find something new to fight for
maybe that's not what you mean to me
swear to me
swear to me that everything you said
about the fireflies is true
oh she knew
I swear
what do you know did you wake up
okay
oh
[Music]
no oh my God
oh this show freaking kills me dude what
uh
absolutely
well Tara it's been nice but I'm gonna
have to finish you off now
oh boy wow here you want to bite
yeah
sure why not keep on going I'll play us
out while you feed the people okay here
you go guys just a little bit by a
little bit everybody can have just a
little bit of lettuce you know
foreign
[Music]
sketch where it's like Andy Samberg and
Will Forte and they're like out on the
they're like on the front steps of like
a New York apartment and they're like
both they're like really opening up to
each other it's like a really dramatic
scene except
they're both just like eating heads of
lettuce
oh yes they're just taking breaks to
like Chomp on some lettuce before going
back to like this dramatic ass like
audition it's all right to feel sad but
the pain goes away
and yes big huge props to Ashley Johnson
again would not have ever picked that
out in the moment but I know I've seen
her face before and and yeah you know as
uh the posting of this reaction Drew
closer obviously I've heard since who
that was and I'm sure you guys have
filled in the comment box already to let
us know and what a cool choice I thought
she did just a the performance was
terrific like she brought so much just
uh desperation and sincerity and warmth
uh to that moment that that whole
prologue and what a perfect choice to
play Ellie's mom like damn like I wish I
had uh Tara in the room to find this out
Troy Baker last week and then Ashley
Johnson this week a couple of the other
actors as well uh uh the guy who played
Tommy his name eludes me here but yeah
like the fact that they chose to include
them and to really allow them to shine
and to have you know memorable moments
and characters especially in the case of
someone important is Ellie's mom like
beautiful beautiful stuff that's funny
uh yeah what what if what an interesting
finale too I mean like you know the
requisite I wonder how the game ends
blah blah blah but like this was such
I guess I I guess I I find myself
frequently asking that question because
this especially as a final episode is so
much of an emotional and a thematic
resili if you want to call it a
resolution I guess you can but it you
know it feels like there's definitely
you know obviously more to come there's
a second game there's a second season at
the very least if not more show beyond
that
um but yeah like this was such an uneasy
ending and I I feel like I'm going to be
processing this for a few days how are
you feeling right now
yeah I mean I think the the biggest
thing is that you the if there was a
moment there that I thought at the end
that Joel wouldn't want to lie to her
um but I'm like yeah it's just so many
lies that he's built up that I'm like
you gotta just keep with it didn't they
am I going crazy or did they not say in
like way earlier in the season like I
don't lie
does or did I make that up because I
have a bad memory but I have a feeling
that somebody it was Ellie or Joel that
said like I don't lie and now I'm like
oh yeah he's he's lying for the sake of
you know of the he loves Ellie out of
love for her
um but it's also a little bit of a
selfish move right where it's now Ellie
really has become his like uh what is it
like Phil and daughter right and I
didn't feel that way before I felt that
he was just he was taking care of her
and he loved her and now it feels very
much like she is sort of a fill-in right
now for Sarah
um yeah a little bit so much so that
he'd he'd he he could have asked her
what she wanted to do but I get he was
pushed up against a wall there he had to
like go and find her and it was
drama but yeah I appreciate that they
played it the way they did I'm very
fascinated to know what people are going
to think about this episode both who
have and haven't played the games
because you do leave off in such a
clearly gray and conflicted place just
the whole displacement of these events
is Harsh and it's it it really gives you
that vital feeling of like a
split-second decision that like once
you've made it you just have to commit
there's no looking back there's that
point of no return and and I thought the
emotionality just the tone and the
feeling that this episode struck both in
the lead up with Ellie being all
reserved and sort of preoccupied as her
journey reaches you know at least
some kind of you know conclusion you
know I don't think she is necessarily
expecting that she won't walk away from
this although you know they have that
conversation where she's like we got to
get this done and then we can go
wherever you want and I feel like you
could read that conversation a couple
ways in the and like one could be yeah
that she really just means that or that
could be her basically you know trying
to soften the blow for Joel in a way
um so you have that as the lead-in and
then you have this like flipperoo where
then Joel becomes the one with this sort
of strange sort of lingering emotional
weight that isn't quite being addressed
and
you know after the more you know like
he's more upbeat
throughout the episode when she is you
know in in whatever little sort of
headspace she's in whatever sort of funk
she's in and then you know later uh it
almost feels like
it's almost like he's bringing up too
much like he's he's it's like it's I'm
so conflicted because it's like it's
cool to see him open up to her about
Sarah and things like that yeah at the
same time you're like I I wonder if this
development is completely genuine or if
this is sort of part of the transaction
of like in order for myself to let go of
it and sort of wall off the things that
I just did but also to kind of you know
keep you feeling like everything is fine
and and good you know I'm gonna start
opening up about this and talking about
how much you guys would have been
friends and whatever else like it's yeah
that was weird yeah right okay it was
weird I was like Joel's hitting it too
far over the head right now I felt like
uh like he's just yeah really talking
about his daughter where I was like oh
yeah this feels not like Joel but he's
like over compensating or something yeah
it's like yeah exactly it's that like
emotional over compensation where it's
like you want to push past
some kind of difficult or traumatic
event so you kind of compensate with
higher energy and more uh just you know
you're more giving with information or
you're more willing to strike
conversation and sort of guide the you
know tone in the room and yeah like I I
it's great because it leaves you wanting
more immediately and I just you know
this the truth of this has to come out
at some point I would imagine and I
cannot obviously I have no idea what
that would mean for their relationship
you know and especially after the lie
it's like you have the twofold it's like
you could maybe Envision a world in
which Ellie's like well I guess I get it
you know like I wouldn't want my brain
to just be dismantled or or at very
least irrevocably damaged in the pursuit
of this maybe maybe she wouldn't mind
you know who knows but uh at the same
time the LIE then solidifies the whole
thing where it's like even if later on
you're like the truth of it isn't the
kicker it's that their new life
ostensibly is now based on a doubling
down on this deceit you know yeah and I
feel like in the beginning we got a
little bit of a highlight of how she
could be if if she had maybe a brain
injury or her brain was a little wonky
she was just in a funk like we all get
in a funk right but Joel could I mean
you could feel the difference with her
and so there's a point when they get to
where it's like it's brain surgery it's
either like yeah you're gonna be messed
up or there's a high risk that you could
die I mean we don't really know there's
only very few doctors like right now
it's probably like yep the one we got is
like gonna give it a go but he might you
might just have to if you're cutting
through her brain they might have just
without saying it like she's going to
die or she's just going to be very
different and we already got a tote a
taste of her being very different in the
beginning which kind of threw Joel off
and kind of threw me off too of like
what's going on we wanted her to to open
up because them together when they're
happy it's such a cool thing to see but
I feel like Joel got a taste of like no
I can't
I can't lose the funny pun uh loving
Ellie right now in his life he's gotten
too attached to who Ellie is like the
talkative always talking let me read my
joke book like give me your gun how can
we do this and he experienced a very
different version of her and I think he
was just like I can't there's no way
that my last time seeing her was that
time sure like nope not signing off on
that which is why I understand why he
killed like 35 people and a good friend
Marlene yeah
it's just like you can't you I I get it
no totally like it's it's uh like it's
such a I I have so many conflicting
feelings right now and it's I I
appreciate the the drama of that I mean
I feel real bad for Marlene especially
after everything she went through and I
mean too I I like that this didn't
spiral into like no they're evil man
like you know the two guards walking
them out are sort of like unnecessarily
callous about the whole thing but other
than that yeah it I I like that they it
seemed like the intent was just like
uh you know you could very much not be
with Joel in this situation like it's
very human you get the Primal just like
I need to get back to my daughter figure
uh but you know he's an older guy like
it's it's a great debate because
either way it seems like Ellie wasn't
given the full spectrum of what was
about to happen and and she should have
the choice the true choice in that yeah
but at the same time you know the choice
gets made for her by much older people
and now you know you're back in this
Dynamic where you know there's maybe
some codependency or something coming
from Joel where it's like you know you
are yeah a much older person who is
making this decision for this much
younger person who yes you have a strong
bond with who you do feel protective for
and rightfully so but yeah where is the
line and and you you crossed it at least
in a couple ways I'm just not sure what
all the ways because yeah it's just it's
it's I feel like any one of us if put in
Joel's position would probably be very
conflicted about what to do here yeah I
feel like it would have one alternate
would be cool to see like I mean
everyone's Dead when he gets to that
surgery room yeah it would be except for
Marlene right you gotta watch how far
come through the door but I'm like you
could have easily said unhook her and
wait until she gets off anesthesia and
then she has the right to be told what's
happening and she has to make the choice
do you want to have surgery the risks
that you may probably die or never be
the same ever again
um to save like a lot of people or do we
get the F out of here
yeah even then I'm like well why it's
tough maybe maybe it would have been too
tough even putting it on her shoulders
maybe it's just easier to take the
choice away and be like well
there's not there's really not because
unless she give is given the choice and
decides yes this is gonna become and
that's and even then it's still like
that's the only version I can imagine
Joel accepting the circumstance under
and the rest of it is like this is a
complete mess because if he was to hold
her up hold up the room and you know
wait for her to wake up and and if she
said no I don't know like they could
easily at least attempt to subdue the
both of them and force her to do it and
that's totally yeah equally grim and
dark work and possible reality in a
situation like this God uh and yeah it's
just been an interesting season because
it has been so linear and it has been uh
very contained in a way and and very
human and very thoughtful and this you
know it concludes you know that initial
Mission set out of we got to get Ellie
to this particular Firefly hospital and
we get there but it's not even like
it's such a significant part of the
episode but it's not even like the main
tone or the main like event that is like
really on display it's just like the
warping like I just have this foreboding
feeling for their relationship moving
forward which is like the biggest the
biggest impact aside from like I mean
the the prologue I thought was beautiful
yeah and heart-wrenching and that
actress who played Ellie's Mom I thought
did a great job I know I've seen her and
stuff
um and yeah I mean I thought the actors
who played Marlene did a great job in
her brief appearances across this and it
was that sort of thing of like oh wow
like they really they really did take
her out that's not all of this and you
feel that desolation of like it's a it's
the epitome of like a a Here and Now
momentary personal victory
but it's so small it's just this one
little microcosm when what was at stake
yeah it's like a whole new future for
the world and it could not have worked
and I get that that too is a part of it
where it's like if this doesn't work
oh but at the same time I don't know I
feel like a part of the Fatal flaw in
his story is he just he's just like and
yeah they just uh decided to stop
looking you know just a bunch of other
kids like you and uh didn't work and
they decided just to stop they just
ended I don't think they would just stop
someone out there would keep this
research going or find a new approach or
a new hypothesis or whatever
but uh yeah oh I mean especially not
after like that moment when she's
feeding and he shows her that she can
feed the giraffe and she's smiling and
he's smiling it's like you can't
I you can just tell it's going to be
burned into his brain and her brain of
like that was that's kind of one of the
very few moments we get to see them both
smiling and like free without a joke
book just in real life and feeling safe
and they're together right
um which was made at such like a
touching moment during that whole time
it was like you finally got to see Ellie
as a kid living feeling safe and she's
with this now like kind of you know Dad
Joel
um and then it just progresses rather
quickly to like we take away the dream
and that's like a tough thing to get
over sure and now that we might have the
dream back but it's it's underlying with
all these lies that are like the bags
gonna open eventually which is like
man I am I just want Joel and Ellie to
be buddies and live together and do cool
things like forever and now we're like
yeah
um stuff's gonna come out and it's not
gonna be good yeah like I feel like yeah
they put you in this position where uh
on appearance that's exactly what's
gonna happen but at the same time it
just couldn't feel further from the
actual case emotionally God every time
I was like leave here being like I need
a nap sure yeah and and I mean across
the season this has been really really
I think fun and interesting in the way
that they've drawn it because it does
feel
it's like the again the show's naturally
going to have some kind of element of a
walking dead brought up in the
conversation
um and having seen a good amount of that
show you know there is a way in which
they they transition from feeling like
yeah you're in this world where you'll
come across different people and people
might die unexpectedly and here you know
you have a bunch of these significant
characters and and side people and and
you know interesting you know through
lines like uh you know a Tommy
especially or a Marlene or or certain
characters like that and
and it's weird like I don't know the way
I think the geography and the journey
has really informed so much so it's like
I like that this is a show that feels
alive in that way it feels populated by
these small appearances but that leave
big impacts and you know these
characters that even if you only see
them briefly you feel like they're still
out there or you wonder about them the
way you might wonder about somebody you
haven't seen in a long time who you
maybe don't have the easiest means of
communicating with and uh and yeah they
build like these great big relationships
that stick with you even after the
episode's over and that's I feel like
that's another thing of like yeah this
great relationship that Joel and Ellie
had and now it's like oh yeah it's gonna
be different now yeah
yeah that's hard I just don't know like
a yeah I'm so
never like not never but seldom do I
reach the end of something like this and
I'm like
we won I guess but we we didn't win
it didn't it's such a fascinatingly un
just unsettled way to leave things off I
suppose I suppose the game must be like
this because I know people often tout
you know how great the story of the game
is and it's being so cinematic so I have
to imagine that this is probably the
flavor that first game kind of ends on
and it does beg a follow-up but for all
the the reasons I wouldn't have expected
like it just begs the emotional
follow-up which is the great thing about
uh again from what I've heard about the
game the game but also this adaptation
and why I think this creative team was a
really smart one to give this to I mean
obviously Neil druckman is involved
heavily but you know Craig Mason and his
side of things like you know
we watched Greg and I that uh uh uh uh
this really big uh deep dive into
the formation of the show and Craig
Mason's Journey over the years
um on on Philip Molina's new channel
film wise is the name of that channel
definitely recommend you guys go check
them out and subscribe if you haven't
already that first video is called The
Last of Us unlocking a surprising genius
and it is we reacted to it here on the
channel you can see sort of our
responses and our first thoughts uh you
know taking it in but it is like a TV
grade look at the road to adapting the
game into the show from a creative and a
filmmaking perspective especially if
you're into like filmmaking in general
as well as this particular show uh it's
it's a really worthwhile video and it's
really well researched and put together
uh Philip and his team killed it so yeah
film wise definitely go check them out
yeah just like hearing about the
emotionality that he wanted to start
portraying after doing all these like
schlock comedies and stuff like that
like it really sings in a place like
this like this is such a thoughtful
emotional uh you know Human Experience
and and two I know people there's been
some small amount of debate online I
guess about how much or not of the
infected are being featured and that's
one way in which I I was kind of
surprised but I never uh have been I've
never been like disappointed
disappointed or taken aback yeah because
that was the one thing I was gonna yeah
there's like no courtesy except for the
beginning but it wasn't like the court
of like the butter lettuce heads that we
were used to sing you were the most
battery lettuce of the whole episode
thing and like I didn't mind it so like
to your point I I'm never left going
like ah we didn't get to see some butter
lettuce heads uh I'm always just stuck
in the emotional journey of it which is
the way to do a show I like that because
it's it's one of the few times like I
feel like often it is said that zombie
movies shows Etc infection outbreak
shows Etc are not about the zombie
action because we've seen that it's
about the human drama but I feel like so
many of those things are at odds with
that very principle and are trying to
please people who do just want to first
and foremost see that Carnage because it
is awesome especially Circa this take
the cordyceps and the fungal take yeah
um but yeah like this is a show that has
to me never felt at odds with that and I
know in the winter episode the the
um cannibal cult episode there was like
a big action scene I guess removed from
there uh that featured many infected and
stuff like that um but even so like they
still feel like this presence and this
looming uh you know just threat that you
know we've seen a couple times where
it's been hordes but a lot of the time
it's been just tense sort of like just
one of them is enough to pose a really
big threat and so yeah it's like as much
as
it always leads to these episodes aren't
exactly what I was expecting yeah in the
best of ways typically in a great way
yeah
what a journey this has been oh man I've
I have no idea what to expect for next
season other than maybe we'll hang out
with Tommy again for a second ah yeah
that would be nice you know I don't know
I feel like they have to it seems like
the the the the DNA of this is them
being out on the road or at least you
know having to move around and invade
and travel and whatnot so I don't know
you know I don't know if the next season
is going to be like we're just shacking
up in Kansas City yeah or uh you know
all right and he would have Tommy would
have his kid by now yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
I don't know strange times although I do
I do Wonder like as much as I know it's
a lie Joel saying like there are a bunch
of other kids like you I mean someone
must have
you know given birth under those
circumstances yeah there had to have
been other people yeah but did they cut
the cord in time sure that's the real
question yeah there you go and that's
yeah and that whole explanation of like
you know because of your unique
circumstance it thinks that it just
recognizes you as itself so it doesn't
need to infect you I was like I don't
know you know any of how
typically if you watch one of those
videos online where a scientist breaks
it down I'm sure that's not at all how
it would work blah blah but it felt very
plausible just yeah within the
suspension of the disbelief of the show
and and yeah just the performances
absolutely you know continue to be
top-notch
um you know Pedro Pascal and Bella
Ramsey have something so special in
their individual presences as well as in
their chemistry and especially in an
episode like this where it's not the
easy going chemistry or the you know
we're both in a fight together kind of
chemistry it's it's such a more
uncomfortable and a breathy sort of uh
you know Airy chemistry in a way like
you feel all this air and this sort of
unspoken tension going on uh and yeah I
just thought it was really really well
crafted across the board yeah you really
you really feel it you do this has been
a roller coaster man this has been crazy
it's been crazy like a roller coaster of
both you know Thrills and ups and down
but also just of Epic emotional
proportions yeah every like almost every
time I leave here going like oh my God
I'm exhausted
this has been a great journey though
thank you for joining me Tara I feel
like we could ramble about this for
hours but uh but yes I I will look
forward to season two I hope you will
join me again oh I will uh because yeah
this has absolutely been a blast and
thank you guys for making this so fun
and for being so receptive again uh this
was all Greg's idea and I know I'd like
I said didn't expect to be on anything
Last of Us related leading into this and
this has been I know a treat for the
both of us just to be able to to do
these in this capacity and yeah to see
the joy that it's brought to you guys
and you guys just being so cool about
you know keeping us abreast of what the
experience was like in the past without
you know explaining without spoiling
anything or giving us too much context
you guys have been great about that you
guys been awesome so thank you for all
the love and for uh the enthusiasm and
uh keep it coming for next season uh you
know if you if you like the last of us T
go show that some love and we'll catch
you for something else in the near
future I hope but uh before we skidads
let's do a little patreon
Ricardo Martinez Ricardo you got an
audition for The Last of Us season two
all right you could be the long lost
third Joel brother whoa yeah yeah that
would be cool forget what did we do we
learned trolls last night it's Martinez
now is it I guess it sounds Joel Martin
I don't think he was actually Hispanic
in the game I'm not sure but you know
you got Gabriel Lunas Tommy you got
Pedro Pascal and I'm just lumping you
all together monolithically as as you
know Latin folks uh but dude Ricardo you
have been with us for a good long time
now and I appreciate your love your
dedication your support and uh and hey
you know if we were in the apocalypse I
feel like you would be an absolute
necessity on our little survival crew I
bet you could help lighten the mood
bring us a few puns but I bet you're
also pretty resourceful and uh and you
know Joel and Tommy both you know pretty
serious kinds of guys they don't want to
laugh a little bit I feel like Ricardo
he can bring the jokes yeah yeah he
knows you're the you're the funny one
yeah it would be like the middle child
you're yucking it up we see you yeah so
stay sexy Ricardo stay funny and uh
we'll catch you on the next one much
love buddy be well bye
[Music]